Ucrania pasó a un segundo plano en este
foro económico mundial el día de hoy y
el cambio climático saltó a la escena
con la participación de la activista
sueca por el clima a greta thunberg
quien vino con toda una comitiva de
activistas climáticos por ejemplo Elena
gualinga de Ecuador también con una
colega alemana se reunieron en un panel
con el jefe de la agencia internacional
de energía con fati virol y presentaron
una carta que van a entregar a los sios
de las compañías energéticas que están
participando en este foro económico en
el que les piden que cesen la apertura
de nuevas sitios de extracción en todo
el planeta pues la industria ha venido
defendiéndose a lo largo de todo este
congreso diciendo que sí debe haber una
transición hacia energías más limpias
pero que esa transición debe ser gradual
así mismo el jefe de la agencia
internacional de energía dijo que
cualquier cambio que se haga tiene que
velar porque en todo caso la seguridad
energética prevalezca en todo el mundo
greta thunberg ya había venido a este
foro lo hizo en 2019 cuando dijo que la
casa estaba Ardiendo en llamas Fue
bastante famosa por esa frase que
pronunció ahora viene a decir
prácticamente lo mismo y a entregarles
este mensaje a las petroleras